so we do track children all over the
world wow I would never have guessed no
so as you can see we have obviously a
lot a lot in in Europe but we have you
know track children's as far as the
Falkland Islands Australia New Zealand
this is the people welfare team at
Blackpool Council and we've been
following them for the last two weeks as
they track down children who aren't in
school this child hasn't been seen since
September and worryingly records show
they have not joined a new school
anywhere else in the last school year
nearly 95 000 children disappeared from
class at some point during the year
we knock on lots of doors and you never
know quite what to expect because you
don't really know what you're going into